handle that moment of opportunity I have
opportunity to show me an opportunity
opportunity spotting new opportunities
of saying yes every opportunity the
opportunity of a lifetime
hello belief nation today I want you to
seize opportunity and as always guys as
you're watching this video if somebody
says something that really means
something to you please leave it down in
the comments below put quotes around as
well so others can be inspired to enjoy
nothing about my life is lucky nothing
a lot of grace a lot of blessings a lot
of divine order but I don't believe in
luck
for me luck is preparation meeting the
moment of opportunity there is no luck
without you being prepared to handle
that moment of opportunity and so what I
would say for myself is is that because
of my hand in a hand and a force greater
than my own
I have been prepared in ways that I
didn't even know I was being prepared
for and the truth is for me and for
every person every single thing that has
ever happened in your life is preparing
you for the moment that is to come
being an actor or even being an artist
and I had studied in school behind the
camera was not even in the vernacular of
my dreams I was raised 9 to 5 you go to
work your work you work your way up a
scale that's real man right yeah and
that was all I was able to even like I
said dream about so the idea of living
life and having a career that was in the
arts that was in the storytelling
business it was something that's really
fun it was not something that like I
said I even dreamed up I was in the
right place right time right bar guy
found me and said you want to come in
and read for a part in a movie I'm here
producing all Dazed and Confused I said
sure I got to read for the part it's got
three lines three lines turns in three
weeks work they're paying me 325 bucks a
day people were telling me I'm pretty
good at it and I think I'm getting away
with something and I still do feel like
I'm getting away didn't you before 17 I
was like the last one to they consider
to become good I mean one day the first
coach of the first team he went out and
he saw me in a game and he was like I
wanna have a meeting with you and I was
like okay what did i do no I mean every
time I had a meeting was for some kind
of disciplinary thing and and then he
said on Monday I start to train with the
big guys here in a first team and then I
was like from considering to be the not
the biggest talent like let's say the
last one in the group to jump over all
of them
and come in the first group and I was
okay and I was
he shot because and I didn't want to say
it too much because maybe if I talk too
much he will change his mind I was like
okay see you on Monday then when they
saw me they saw the player that was
different from the other ones it was a
great feeling but at the same time I was
like now I have opportunity to do
something good out of it and it's pretty
it's up to me so if I want to to become
something that I think I can become I
have to train hard and that's my
mentality I would like to train hard I
mean you can have talent but talent
don't take you all the way I was
challenged by my manager right now a
producer DJ tone and my cousin who
passed away they challenged me all this
was a bad 12 13 years ago 98 he was 17 8
17 18 and they challenged me to stop
selling drugs stop selling cracking they
say you want to be a rapper this is what
you want to do
you've already been arrested you've
already gotten you did just just a
little bit of time you got probation if
you get arrested again you blow it all
so I then said okay we'll take me
somewhere where I can where I can create
a way for myself if you want me to leave
this behind then make Nick make up maybe
show me an opportunity they then took me
to a studio with a group named pa pa
then put me on the spot asking me if I
could rap on a certain beat I walked in
the booth did my thing and they signed
me to LaFace roughest
carry cheering I had I would say 90% of
the business coming out of Taiwan
because she spoke Taiwanese and she sold
condominiums and then one day I'm
watching the news early and I see the
Taiwanese stock market if there's such a
thing some big Taiwanese thing crashed
I'm sitting there like oh my god Kerry
is gonna be over here she was producing
single-handedly I must have had maybe a
hundred and fifty salespeople at the
time she was single-handedly producing
80 percent of my income this is
important all my eggs were in the carry
basket I immediately call carried up on
her first cell phone her second cell
phone her home her office her Chinese
cousins
cannot reach it next act that reaches
she's disappeared I know Carrie has
committed Harry Caray all I wanted to do
was get a hold of her to let her know
we'd figured something out or know what
but I knew we'd figure something out
don't worry
she finally marches into my office as
she always does like she owns it
she's always insulted me a little but
what the heck she'd make him money I'll
settle watches into my office I got
Carrie I wanted to say you're alive but
I thought she was dead she does know
Karen would you do things
what poetry emotion themselves
concatenate she let her hair growth over
a foot or a brass hair or whatever those
things evolved it she saw the
opportunity and what do you think Kerry
did she hired two Japanese speaking
assistants with it I'd say a week and a
half
how does she find them right because the
Japanese market was booming and she had
them as the interlayer she showed
apartments to the Japanese and let me
tell you I found out in that chapter the
Japanese really don't like the chase and
they loved buying the Chinese apartments
at a steep discount and carry like
double their business Norman sells more
property the Japanese today the koh yang
no one sells in with chinese and if
anything happens to those markets I'm
sure she'll go to school learn how to
speak German or Russian or whatever the
heck she has to learn how to do a
wonderful example of someone who takes a
hit a successful business person needs
to exploit the market but the sector of
they're in they need to have a great
understanding of it they need to
constantly monitor the market place and
spot opportunities that's what
successful business is all about
spotting new opportunities and
exploiting them most success stories in
expansion of businesses are based upon
enhancements learnt from the core
business that you're already in adding
additional features to products
expanding product ranges ideas that come
from what you're already doing
particularly in manufacturing your own
employees can actually come up with some
spark of genius in streamlining the
production process so that you may have
never thought about before
so anything that could save you lots and
lots of money or suddenly come up with
an idea based upon the product that
you're producing that is allied to what
do you believe set apart people like
Steve Jobs and Mark Zuckerberg and Bill
Gates apart from their character they
happen to be in particular markets the
personal computer market for Steve Jobs
and Bill Gates and the internet for Mark
Zuckerberg
where they had spent their youth and
formative years assembling knowledge
that and the deep interest in a
particular topic that the rest of the
world didn't know very much about so
when the time came to germinate their
ideas they were ready and poised unable
to do that and obviously then showed
their mettle as entrepreneurs because
there were lots of other people who were
there at the same time but who caught
who subsequently failed whereas these
people succeeded tell us when you were
just starting out if you're all big and
successful but bad wait a long time ago
in the day when you were just first
turned out what were your most
successful marketing strategies well I
think if we're what we're talking about
really is building a business off of the
brand of building a business off to
getting things done model and
methodology that actually developed many
many years after I was doing the work
and consulting and coaching but didn't
market myself Marketing is called pick
up the phone you know it was all
referrals whatever but even back then I
have to say you know job one called that
work engage like don't turn down any
opportunity to talk to anybody about
what you're doing as long as they're you
know have a positively inclined you know
so you know if they're trying to talk to
you beat you up or run you down or you
know to prove that they're better than
you that that's probably not worthwhile
but you know most people are often
gracious about that and you know so you
gotta ask there nobody got to put
yourself out so that's what I'm done I
have continued to do that as the book
came out then I had opportunities people
would you know I got press on that that
the book publisher you know produce but
I took advantage of every single podcast
every single interview every single like
this like you Stephanie made me to use
anything that they want to talk to
people I got sure I'll talk to people so
I'm not actually a naturally extroverted
personally it actually is something I do
need to focus on and you know it's not
like I get all my juice out of that so
it is a consciously done thing and I
think out of you know hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of
request and and would you write an
article about or whatever I think I've
only turned down one there just seemed
to be a bit sleazy you know my wife is
my chief executive assistant you know
she just she provides a little bit of a
filter for me about those kind of things
but I take advantage of all of that so
that's job one because I just say yes to
any opportunity saying yes to every
opportunity and you know also just in
terms of my stuff many times much like a
bump mr. fuller just to say he never he
never you learned what he knew by
talking to people because he said yeah a
BS meter that would go off inside of him
if he was talking to people that's where
you learn and I I'm pretty much the same
way so it's not only a one-way street
man you're helping other people out
there but I also matured a lot of my
thinking about what I was doing and how
to express it
by doing that when you realized that
wasn't a joke where's your first
instinct stay away from it or was it
percolating in the back of your head
somewhere is a great idea it was a
couple of things happening the most
first things thing was dude dude it's
the opportunity of a lifetime really
kidding me what a gift but then as the
next thought was but if you get up good
night your career is over
mmm period you know because you know in
film you know my career has been decent
and I can't say I have a string of
amazing films under my belt
you know if week I've got great films
and films are very from popcorn films to
some really heartfelt films but you know
Mandela was a next-level for me and it
was absolutely the gateway to the next
chapter of my career but had I and I get
to the Gateway and tripped up as I
forward in I wouldn't never I won't be
moving on because he's such a big world
global citizen you know and and I had
all this sort of trepidation about you
know when I don't look like mr. Mandela
I thought how how am I gonna do this you
know but Justin was really clear about
his vision and it was a different spin I
guess
and then one day lo and behold while I
was crossing on my way to the campus
this photographer by the name Peter
beard stopped me and said have you ever
been photographed before mind you I've
never seen in fashion magazines in my
life I've never worn makeup or heels for
that matter so I had no idea what he was
talking about but I thought oh here we
go another white man who thinks Africans
have never seen a camera before I've
never been photographed
I said yes I have and he said what
magazine and I said my parents and he
said I'd like to take your pictures and
as I walked kept on walking he said the
magic word he said I'll tell you and I
said well how much he said well how much
they went and I riding there and there
on the streets of Nairobi on my way to
campus I made my first modeling
transaction and I said $8,000 because
that was the tuition and a couple of
months later he brought the pictures
land to America and they called for me
and a big year since then thank you guys
so much for watching I'd love to know
what you thought of the video what was
your favorite clip what was the message
that really resonated the most with you
leave it down in the comments below I'm
also curious do you seize opportunities
enough did you take home something from
this that you're now going to apply to
your life to your business leave in the
comments I'm gonna join in the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love guys
I'll see you soon